[Musik]
nein nicht so wunderschöner morgen denn
es ist gerade nacht erwartet um sie in
unserer kleinen fußballfeld meine lieben
freunde zum ende der letzten folge habe
ich euch ja gesagt ich gehe auf eine
challenge ein und versuche diese
challenge umzusetzen dass ich dass ich
drei tage lang nicht schlafen meiner
minecraft weil mir gesagt wurde dass ich
das nicht schaffe und ich dachte es geht
dabei nur um monster die dann eventuell
kommen aber nein hier wurden die
kommentare geschrieben dass dann auch
nicht mit mir wir starten ganz normal
wie sonst auch immer in die em ein
kraftvoll gemisch mit einem
wunderschönen guten morgen da habt ihr
mich wirklich bisschen an der nase herum
gibt
ahlmann wir haben für heute allerdings
sind etwas hervor und
was soll ich mit euch machen
eine hunde gassi balu und denen sie
können den später
[Musik]
wo kann trainiert er ist die immer so
random creepers portmann bitte ganz kurz
wieder zurück ins wasser und bildung
kleinerer blöder idiot ich packe ich
auch direkt mal wieder zurück hier ins
ist ja noch eine
denn das nun die schildkröten hier also
bei lewis drin und valencia ist drin und
jetzt meine lieben freunde zeige ich
euch erst mal ganz kurz was in der
heutigen episode vorhabe denn das habe
ich auch schon der letzten episode
angekündigt ich möchte hier vorne hallo
papa ich möchte hier vorne einen
luftballon hinbauen beziehungsweise
vielleicht doch noch ein paar mehr die
sache ist allerdings dass ich in meiner
test welt schon geschaut habe wie viele
ressourcen nicht eigentlich habe und ich
hab nicht mal die ressourcen für einen
luftballon von daher um es mal ganz kurz
erklärt ich brauche eine menge beton und
ich brauche auf jeden fall noch ein
halbes leksand und noch mehr als 1
beckys deswegen würde ich direkt mal
runter gehen in die höhle nicht in die
hölle das sind zwei verschiedene welten
und können wir hier erst mal ein
bisschen sand den brauchen wir nicht den
habe ich ja damals nur hier hin gebaut
war ich halt dachte dass ich hier
eventuell eine bambus fahren mache
beziehungsweise zuckerrohr farben und
das ist ja doch nichts geworden hier
unten soll immer noch der bunker reihen
keine ahnung ob ich den noch bauen werde
ich will eigentlich die ganzen projekte
die ich noch habe umsetzen während
dieser letzten 19 folgen mittlerweile ja
nur noch allerdings ist eine ganz kurze
time lips wie ich hier den sandabbau wie
ich mir noch kies hole und generell die
sachen zusammen kräfte die ich für den
luftballon benötige
[Musik]
so ich bin fertig vorbereitet und ihr
seht doch schon ich habe eine menge
roten trocken beton ich habe eine menge
fichtenholz dinge wie beispielsweise
bretterzaun tore und stufen und ich habe
auch schon seerosenblätter lernen denn
das seerosen blatt wird uns nachher
helfen dass wir uns passend hoch bauen
können denn der ballon soll direkt hier
vorne stattfinden ich habe mir erst
gedacht dass ich in meiner selbst das
kann ich euch sofort zeigen musste
allerdings erst mal hier ganz kurz
markieren hier vorne soll nämlich seien
sogar sehr sehr nahe hier vorne dran ihr
seht nachher auch warum der wird nämlich
nicht alt zug riesig denn er hat auch
gar keine funktion und soll einfach ein
deko element sein ich wollte den erst
hier vorne hin bauen dort enden die
richtung haben noch gar nichts die sache
ist allerdings dass hier die südseite
ist und die sonne scheint den ballon
dann von der falschen seite an und dann
legt er auch wenn der rot ist ziemlich
dunkel und es sieht nicht so schön aus
dann wirft auch einen schatten auf
unsere insel die sache ist allerdings
dass ich ja leider roten trocken beton
habe ich benötige allerdings normalen
beton und deswegen muss ich den jetzt
erstmal hier ordentlich daran setzen
[Musik]
so freunde hat es doch noch mal zwölf
minuten gedauert den ganzen trocken
beton hierhin zu setzen und wieder
abzubauen so das ist normaler beton wird
allerdings habe ich hier 220 oder sogar
noch ein bisschen mehr von dem trocken
beton damit müssen wir allerdings gar
nicht erst mal anfangen sondern erstmal
mit den fichten holzbrettern ihr wisst
ja ich liebe pflicht deswegen mache ich
auch hier den ballon aus fichtenholz und
ich habe mir auch gerade überlegt dass
ich den vielleicht doch noch ein
bisschen weiter vorne ins mehr einsätze
weiße ballon der fig ja auch immer nie
so nah an häusern her von daher hier
erstmal das seerosen platin oder fange
ich jetzt wahrscheinlich warum hier ein
seerosen blatt ganz einfach aus dem
grund weil ich mich sonst vom boden aus
bis nach oben hoch bauen müsste um hier
überhaupt den ersten richtigen login
setzen zu können jetzt kann ich einfach
so machen und hier ein blog hinsetzen
und ich habe auch noch extra ein
bisschen mehr dicht neues mitgebracht so
dass ich das so ein bisschen als
plattform benutzen kann nicht bei den
ballon jetzt auf jeden fall ein 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 fache höhe um das
oder vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen
niedriger glaub ich weil das hier unten
ist ja die situation
warum sagen die situation
gar keinen sinn auf jeden fall geht es
hier los denn das hier ist der bereich
wo man dann quasi drin steht da werden
wir zwar nie drin stehen ich habe zu
beginn schon gesagt es ist er nico
element der balloon hier vorne
allerdings muss auch das natürlich
durchdacht sein von daher hier das
eingangstor oder quasi reingehen hier
vorne auch nochmal fichtenholz bretter
hin und hier an die saiten fichtenholz
zäune so dass es ganz natürlich gut
gesichert ist aber ist aufgefallen dass
ein ballon ist er 0 gesichert
er liegt beim flieger du schneidest dich
an du hast das an sicherheit sachen und
dies und blauen ballon
muss einfach so ein vogel rad und bahn
weg vom himmel das passiert uns und
minecraft natürlich nicht denn hier gibt
es perfekt hier gibt es tatsächlich
keine vögel eventuell gibt es die
allerdings in staffel 2 von minecraft
mit luca müssen wir abwarten ob ich da
sondern bot installiere dass da so ein
paar tiere mit drin sind allerdings
konzentrieren wir uns erstmal noch auf
diese staffel hier denn wir müssen uns
jetzt erstmal ganz kurz hoch bauen bzw
die blöcke unter uns auch direkt wieder
abbauen denn die sondern natürlich nicht
bleiben das ist schon ein bisschen
schwierig dass wir uns jetzt gerade
dieser schwindligen die höhe hier fort
bauen das war es auf jeden fall was wir
die ganzen fichtenholz machen mussten
wir mussten erst mal ganz kurz hier
vorne hoch kommen und hier kommen
kommen lichtpunkt hier kommen wir jetzt
nämlich auch schon zu unserem richtigen
balance also zu diesem ding
das verstopft habe keine ahnung ist ja
auch egal ich find das alles ein
bisschen suspekt perfekt direkt den
ersten rocky falsch gesetzt ihr seht
schon ich habe hier da wo die zeile
hochgehen einen roten kreis umgesetzt
und jetzt kommt's an jede seid ihr hier
und hier und hier auch sagt rother beton
dran wir gehen jetzt mal ein höher die
sache ist ihr könnt das ganze natürlich
auch auf volle bauen sieht dann
wahrscheinlich sogar noch ein bisschen
geiger aus allerdings ist wolle
schwierig immer in kraft da bauen wir
damit eine menge fäden für oder eine
menge schafe ich habe weder noch und
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht ich mache
es mit beton weil das mit kies und sand
ein bisschen besser aussieht und ich
finde auch die farben ehrlich gesagt so
ein bisschen klima als wolle sobald wir
diesen eckigen kreis jetzt haben bauen
wir auf jede spitze sondern kleines t
also 1 und block stieg die ab und dann
brauchen wir da oben quasi drei
betonblöcke noch mal drauf und dann hier
drinnen baut man das ganze so also 12
zack nee das ist falsch
[Musik]
so bauen wir das ganze also hier bam bam
und dann immer einen nach außen also und
hier vorne auch beim bam bam und hier
vorne auch bam bam bam das video wenn
ihr das ganze nachbarn wolf pack ich
euch hat wahrscheinlich natürlich wieder
unten die beschreibung check das geld
aus und wenn ihr schon in der
beschreibung seid ihr doch auf instagram
folgen dann neues foto hochgeladen
drei wochen neues foto hochgeladen jetzt
gehen wir an den seiten auf jeden fall
fünf blöcke in jede richtung
beziehungsweise ja mehr drei blöcke und
dann gehen wir noch mal einen block
weiter
genau das gleiche nun auch auf dieser
seite und dann auch jetzt hier vorne auf
der letzten seite zack und zack und
jetzt gehen wir hier auf jeder seite
zwei blöcke in die höhe allerdings auch
hier vorne über die saiten rum und dass
das hier quasi so jetzt mittlerweile
sogar schon der mittelpunkt vom
leuchtturm ist der wahl wieder falsch
perfekt so zack zack die sache ist das
rein ballon alleine mal so ein bisschen
einsam aussieht finde ich gerade wenn
man so am himmel so ein balance finde
ich das aber so ein bisschen ruhig
deswegen habe ich mir überlegt dass wir
eventuell demnächst nochmal ein paar
mehr balance bauen und dann nicht nur
einen roten ballon haben sondern dann
noch irgendwie einen blauen hier neben
so ein bisschen tiefer und noch einen
gelben oder so hier so ein bisschen
höher könnte mir gerne in die kommentare
schreiben was ihr davon haltet nun gehen
wir oben allerdings wieder so ein
bisschen spitz dazu und machen das nicht
über die komplette länge sondern wieder
nur fünf
betonblöcke und auf die fünf betonblöcke
setzen wir dann auch nur noch mal drei
betonblöcke also quasi genau so wie wir
das unten gemacht haben und jetzt auch
wieder auf der innenseite unser l wo ich
mich zu beginn ein bisschen verbaut habe
leider nur sind wir hier oben angekommen
und bauen nur noch diese ecken hier eben
fix zu dann hier vorne 1 231 moment 13 1
2 3 und 4 um 1 23 und dann nur noch das
hier in der mitte schnell zu bauen und
sind wir quasi schon fertig mit dem
ballon die sache ist allerdings dass wir
hier an die seiten jetzt auch noch etwas
dran bauen müssen und da ist jetzt die
frage wie ich das mache ich muss mich da
so ein bisschen her handeln denn hier in
die mitte muss ein blog dann müssen hier
welche runter wir müssen dann allerdings
auch wieder ein bisschen weiter runter
ich hoffe dass ich das jetzt irgendwie
hinkriege das ist halt ein bisschen blöd
in seiner schwindligen höhe baut ich
hoffe mich packen das jetzt da ihnen die
runter zu gehen also einmal so zack zack
hier das fichtenholz abgebaut und dann
hier noch mal beim namen und hier vorne
auch noch einen ich hoffe mal dass ich
kann jetzt nicht hin so ich hoffe dass
das jetzt richtig gebaut habe denn das
gleiche müssen wir jetzt auch noch mal
hier auf die andere seite bauen also ich
hier einen blog in ihr dann zack linie
richtung und hier nochmal das sollte
allerdings richtig sein von daher freue
ich mich jetzt ja auch noch mal zu
anderen seite eben rum das ist auf jeden
fall sehr gut so wie ich das gerade
macht mit dem gerüst was ich mir so ein
bisschen drumherum setzte wenn man das
im creative modus natürlich danach baut
also ihr dann beispielsweise in eurer
welt dann kann man natürlich ein
bisschen einfacher einfach drum herum
fliegen und so das ist für mich jetzt
allerdings gerade natürlich nicht
möglich einen letzten eichenholz blog
habe ich noch und das passt jetzt auch
perfekt ins bamm bamm bamm bamm bamm
bamm bamm dann sollte der ballon auch
eigentlich schon fertig sagt ich brauche
sie mal ganz fix das gerüst hier eben
drum herum ab das brauche ich jetzt auf
jeden fall nicht mehr aussieht nachher
nur blöde aus die sache ist dass die
sonne dahin tatsächlich jetzt schon
wieder untergeht und an der stelle würde
ich dann auch gleich die heutige episode
minecraft mit beenden ich weiß nicht ob
die folge jetzt ein bisschen länger war
da ein bisschen kürzer ich bin halt in
der aufnahme schon wieder bei fast einer
stunde
es waren allerdings natürlich wieder
zwei sehr lange time labs mit drin die
sache ist allerdings dass ich gerade
leider wieder ein bisschen stress habe
ich muss gleich meinen zug erwischen
weil ich nach berlin fahre über das
wochenende die nächste folge wird aber
definitiv wieder ein bisschen länger das
haben sich viele gewünscht dass man die
lage in episoden zurück kommen sollen
ich brauch erst mal ganz kurz fällt mir
aber eben auch hier vorne meinen gerüst
auch ab das geht ja noch bis zum ballon
oben hin ich hoffe dass ich jetzt
überhaupt dran kommen sonst muss ich da
gleich auch immer ein bisschen hoch
bauen und perfekt es hat geklappt ok
super wir vorne noch mal kurz das
fichtenholz abbauen und den untersten
blog auch geforderte see rosenblatt und
dann sammle ich jetzt noch mal eben fix
hier meine ganzen retter ein die hier
vorne noch überall rum schwimmer im
wasser die fische das ist echt
wundervoll ich weiß noch genau die erste
episode minecraft mit blue card wo ich
auf dieser kleinen insel hinten gespannt
bin wo mittlerweile der leuchtturm steht
und drüber geschwommen bin und überhaupt
erst mal das ganze seht alle her gesehen
hab die ganzen fische gesehen hat und
mir einfach nur ich dachte nicht
angegriffen ich habe einfach keine luft
bekommen die sonne geht unter
ach das war doch dieser fisch ist aber
egal freunde wir haben heute nur
positive vibes in der folge denn wir
haben einen ballon gott der sie wollen
das aus
als er das hätte ich niemals gedacht
dass der doch so wild aussieht
vor allem mit dem himmel im hintergrund
[Musik]
sind mal ganz kurz hier den michael
phelps rausholen ich gehe auch mal ganz
fix eben schnell schlafen so dass wir
uns den sonnenaufgang noch einmal mit
dem ballon zusammen angucken können also
eben ganz schnell hier nach oben den
village in uppsala den village oder eben
kurz aus dem bett wagenbauer ein hier
wir können uns jetzt nochmal beim
sonnenaufgang angucken und dann zeige
ich euch auch warum es mehr sinn machte
den ballon dorthin zu setzen anstatt was
ich ja irgendwann mal angekündigt habe
da vorne noch was hin zu bauen denn das
jetzt wirklich sehr wild so zwischen den
bäumen der vorleser ballon mit ihr
stellt euch vorhin eben doch so ein
kleiner blauer und linien sondern so ein
gelber noch irgendwie in der
es auch besser so denn ich gehe jetzt
auch meine lieben freunde wenn es euch
heute gefallen hat die webisode frau
kraft mit luca lassen einen daumen hoch
und der video hier abonnieren ein kanal
und trinkt auf die glocke fahrzeug ein
teil der crew seit und neue videos nicht
verpassen wollt schreibt zu geben bitte
bitte bitte bitte bitte bitte gerne in
die kommentare was in der nächsten
episode machen soll soll ich die beiden
balance in der nächsten episode
vielleicht direkt schon bauen er sieht
schon echt sehr sehr sehr sehr wild aus
der favorit oder soll ich in die höhe
gehen die wir sind in der wüste entdeckt
haben oder soll ich etwas ganz anderes
machen sind wir wieder in die heutigen
station in die kommentare wir sehen uns
übermorgen wieder
[Musik]